ça c'est just walkout d'Amazon c'est une
techno qui est intéressante en fait ce
que vous avez c'est une reconnaissance
au niveau de votre main donc vous prenez
vous posez votre main dessus hop là
quelques parts par là et vous rentrez
directement dans le magasin et après
c'est comme dans tous les les boutiques
Amazon vous avez plus qu'à prendre un
produit que vous voulez un ou des
produits est-ce que ce qui va se passer
en fait c'est que vous avez tout un
réseau de caméra qui est en haut et qui
va venir reconnaître les produits que
vous voulez prendre avec vous donc vous
prenez les produits prenez vous reposer
lui sera exactement ce que vous avez
pris vous ressortez directement vous
êtes débité je vous a vachement malin
parce qu'en fait c'est une nouvelle
façon de rentrer dans les magasins on se
prend pas la tête on prend les produits
et on s'embête pas c'est facile c'est
simple vous avez plus qu'à choisir vous
prenez vous partez et puis comme ça on
se pose pas de questions l'idée je
trouve pas con alors après on va se dire
effectivement ça met des gens au chômage
ou pas j'en sais rien je pense qu'en
fait c'est une nouvelle façon de
consommer c'est une petite révolution
dans l'industrie l'alimentaire et pas
que de l'alimentaire parce que ils ont
même lancé des magasins au niveau du
prêt-à-porter bon ça c'est une autre
histoire l'appareil prochaine fois puis
ensuite j'ai plus qu'à Apple sortir et
voilà fini